sí
el último paso para completar el
simulador de partículas es desarrollar
un método para monitorear el movimiento
de las partículas en el tiempo así es
como nuestro programa informático las
animará 4x4
anteriormente dijimos que si conocemos
la ecuación de movimiento de cada
partícula
podemos calcular sus velocidades y
posiciones pero exactamente como lo
hacemos para responder esta pregunta
retomemos el concepto de velocidad como
la pendiente de la posición en relación
con la curva del tiempo
tomemos los valores de tiempo de 12
cercanos entre sí
supongamos que p 1 es la posición en el
tiempo de 1 y p2 es la posición en el
tiempo de 2
la pendiente de la recta l aquí mostrada
es una buena aproximación de la
velocidad de uno en el tiempo de uno
entre más cerca esté de dos de tf1 mejor
será la aproximación
vista como una ecuación la pendiente de
l esto es la velocidad de 1 está dada
por el cambio la posición dividido entre
el cambio en el tiempo si conocemos la
posición y la velocidad en el tiempo de
1 entonces podemos calcular la posición
en el tiempo t 2 reordenando esta
ecuación para obtener p 2
muy bien entonces una vez que conocemos
la posición y la velocidad de la
partícula en el tiempo de uno podemos
calcular su posición en el tiempo t 2
usando esta fórmula
pero como obtenemos la velocidad en el
tiempo de dos bueno si conocemos la
ecuación de movimiento podemos calcular
la aceleración en el tiempo t 2 por
ejemplo si únicamente la gravedad está
actuando sobre la particular entonces la
aceleración es constante y está dada por
la constante gravitacional g también
sabemos que la aceleración es la
pendiente de la velocidad en relación
con la curva de tiempo lo cual significa
que la gravedad es igual al cambio en la
velocidad dividido entre el cambio en el
tiempo
también podemos obtener de 2
ahora que conocemos pedos y b2 podemos
repetir este proceso para calcular p3
ib3 y así sucesivamente tantas veces
como queramos pongamos un ejemplo
supongamos que al comienzo de nuestra
simulación establecemos nuestro
parámetro de tiempo temps en cero
nuestra particular es ese punto pero no
con velocidad de 1 y el vector gravedad
que apunta hacia abajo para determinar
dónde estará la partícula cuando el
tiempo temp sea igual a 0.5 usamos la
actuación de 2 igual a b1 que multiplica
a la cantidad de 2 menos de 1 y a esto
le sumamos p 1 donde t 1 es igual a 0 y
t2 es igual a 0.5 entonces b 2 es igual
a 0.5 b 1 más
lo que significa que pedos está a mitad
de camino entre la cola y la cabeza de
v1 y para determinar b2 decimos que pe 2
es igual a g por la cantidad de t 2
menos de 1 y a esto le sumamos b 1 aquí
que es el vector gravitacional que
apunta hacia abajo y que en la tierra
tiene una magnitud de 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado
una vez más dedos de 10.5 así que m2 es
igual a 0.5 g más b 1
bien ahora podemos calcular la posición
y la velocidad entre igual a 1 usando
las mismas fórmulas
resulta bastante tedioso hacer esto a
mano pero es relativamente sencillo
programar una computadora para que haga
todos estos cálculos por nosotros como
este
felicidades ahora tenemos todos los
elementos que necesitamos para crear un
simulador de pelotas de ping pong
en el último ejercicio podrás poner a
prueba tus conocimientos acerca de estos
conceptos antes de empezar a crear tus
propias y sorprendentes simulaciones de
partículas